knock knock let the devil in manipulate
as i've ever been headed
venom let there be carnage is the exact
type of movie i wanted to see when i was
eight years old
and i mean that in the best possible way
andy circus's bonkers balls to the wall
sequel released just this october after
being delayed delayed undelayed delayed
again but now it's out and it's exactly
what i expected and wanted from it
this is exactly what a movie about venom
would be at least the venom from the ps1
game or the 90s cartoon or any of his
comic appearances after he stopped being
a full-on villain
tell me this einstein who could have
wanted to steal octavius's technology oh
we know we know who
the submariner submariner get serious
will you the mighty thor are you out of
your mind
don't answer that
galactus forget it eddie that version of
venom is a wonderful combination of
silly and edgy and i can't believe we
live in a world where we get to see that
on the big screen instead of like the
more contemporary venom that's not
played for laughs
from the various references and nods to
old comic runs to the overall tone and
style this movie is full of stuff that
really made me smile as someone who grew
up on old back issues of the 90s venom
as some of the first comics i ever read
in short let there be carnage is a
loving tribute to 90s comic book edgy
trash now obviously this review is going
to be kind of spoiler heavy so uh
all throughout the movie i saw things i
never would have thought they'd pull
from the comics in a million years but i
guess the writers did their research and
were huge fans of 90s venom stories i
feel like i'm not seeing anyone really
appreciate just how much of a love
letter this is to those books so let's
go over all the random odds and ends
from the classic venom stories that
ended up incorporated into venom let
them eat cake the plot is a combination
of the hunger maximum carnage carnage
unleashed and that other storyline also
called the hunger which is a little
confusing with eddie and the symbiote at
odds about the alien's hunger for human
brains and want and destruction causing
the suit to leave eddie and run around
draining the life out of various hosts
and being a menace while eddie is
institutionalized for his crimes as
venom cletus cassidy's backstory is
pulled right from the pages of the books
with his slang of his grandma and his
abusive childhood his time in saint
estes home for boys when he was a
troubled orphan which he burned down as
a kid it's here where he would first
encounter spider-man and demolish an
innocent teddy bear which is assuredly
one of his most horrific crimes of all
except in the movie they have carnage
burned down saint estes as an adult for
the cathartic feeling of revenge now
that he's got his powers and is painting
the town appropriately red we also have
carnage breaking out of cletus cassidy's
body when he's strapped to a table and
injected
enjoy the show
in the comics it was a tranquilizer when
he was going to ravencroft at the
beginning of maximum carnage but here
it's a lethal injection viewers can
later see the reference that shocked me
the most which is that carnage's
symbiote can interact with the internet
ironically this made more sense in the
comics because he was just sending thin
tendrils through the phone lines to
attack people with shitty 90s dial up
internet
i have no idea how the hell this works
in modern day but the fact that they
included it at all made me laugh out
loud in the theater patrick mulligan was
toxin in the comics and served as the
goofy symbiote character after venom
comics got more serious in the early
2000s with a similar straight man
comedian and good cop bad cop vibe as
eddie in his suit the decade prior
he makes it into the movie as a cop that
attempts to stop carnage but is infected
with his spawn in the hectic fight
setting him up as a potential antagonist
in the third movie i always dug how
toxin could transition from a
spider-man-like form to a monstrous
design that looked more reminiscent of
venom and carnage i enjoyed his small
mini-series from the 2000s and i'm still
really salty that he was just killed off
panel by blackheart from ghostwriter to
set up some crazy event for flash
thompson venom ever since they haven't
really known what to do with toxin
between all these hosts and being killed
off like three times
so maybe venom three can point them in
the right direction and maybe give the
general public more of an interest in
mulligan's character again so marvel can
either revive him or at least give that
character a proper death and send off
after the big explosive climax venom
separates cletus and carnage and then
eats the symbiote in front of cletus as
he's horrified and powerless and that's
taken directly from peter parker
spider-man from the year 2000
right as the 90s era of silly symbiote
shenanigans started to end oddly enough
though cletus found another symbiote in
the negative zone then just like turned
that into carnage with the remnants of
the original suit in his body i guess
and then also spider-man was there in a
new costume from the spider-man
unlimited cartoon and then they fight an
evil warlord from the negative zone
named blastar and yeah sometimes you
don't need to be that accurate to the
comic books because that's really
convoluted and dumb so instead venom
just eats cletus's head and that's it
it's unfortunate that the reign of
carnage had to end so quickly but
there's about 4 000 story lines where
venom was about to kill him and then
that pansy-ass bleeding heart liberal
spider-man is like no we can
rehabilitate him bro but with no
spider-man yet and there's no one to say
no it makes sense for the characters
honestly we end with eddie and the
symbiote hiding his fugitives from the
law on an island which he did for a
while after being falsely led to believe
he killed spider-man in the books but
due to peter parker in the mcu being a
blithering buffoon that's always
slipping on banana peels and wetting his
pants venom and eddie have been
transported into the mcu whether that's
a permanent change or not i have no idea
does that mean venom is in no way home
is that him way in the background
instead of lizard i have no idea
is he the invisible one that kicks
lizard right in the chops probably not
that'll be like andrew will toby maguire
spider-man tell tom holland spider-man
that he almost had his face ripped off
once by a journalist named eddie brock
bonded with a sludge monster from space
resulting in tom holland spider-man
seeing this guy and immediately trying
to punch him in the dick
a reporter named eddie brock tried to
kill me
he turned into a monster after bonding
with a symbiote
they almost bit my face off
[Music]
simeones are really dangerous stay away
from those things
i'd recommend preventing that from
happening on your world
that'd be kind of forced but hell why
not venom does mention that the symbiote
hive mind can see across universes 80
billion light years of hive knowledge
across universes would explode your tiny
little brain
so maybe he saw his and eddie's variants
getting killed by a spider-man that
resulted in immediate hatred and set up
their rivalry fire a betting man i'd say
the plan is to have venom 3 be
spider-man vs venom in the first half
then eddie loses the suit halfway
through and is taken prisoner by some
outside force causing venom and spidey
to bond together to go bust him out
giving venom his trademark creepy spider
logo and a demented version of peter's
powers
pretty much the plot of that spider-man
unlimited episode i'm the only one who
remembers that show exists
for a while i wasn't really set on the
casting for venom and carnage in my mind
for the last few years they always
should have been played by dominic
purcell and walton goggins but tom hardy
and woody harrelson both really won me
over in this one after about 20 minutes
of the movie i stopped seeing woody
harrelson and started just really seeing
cletus cassidy and that's an awesome
feeling as someone that adored these
characters as a kid what i love about
venom let there be cartilage is that it
knows exactly the type of movie it wants
to be and achieves that marvelously in
my book it doesn't want to be your
typical mcu movie where the characters
stop point at the comic book silliness
and then say wow isn't that dumb
directly to the audience in hopes that
the audience will play along instead of
lampshading the absurdity of its source
material it embraces it with open arms i
don't love it solely because it's a list
of references and recreated scenes from
comics because that can be hollow and
boring if done improperly what makes
these moments and the whole movie shine
for me is that it understands the tone
and feeling of those moments too and
recreates them lovingly with what feels
like a solid understanding of why those
books are flawed but also incredibly fun
and charming edgy 90s comics from marvel
and dc had such a specific unique feel
to them with storylines they were
ultimately guided mostly towards the
biggest and craziest bad guy you could
fight propping up a hero that would have
been considered a villain 10 years
earlier venom books weren't high art in
this time period they were wacky and
stupid and funny and full of jokes and
allusions to extreme violence that they
couldn't actually show on panel
this pg-13 film either by design or pure
coincidence after being censored from an
r rating has captured that exact feeling
of lovable trashiness that wants to seem
really violent and gory but is still
safe for kids
what the [ __ ] are you doing back there
why are you playing with a fidget
spinner while i'm recording anna
i love you it feels like it was made by
people who truly love the character
i'm fully aware this movie isn't very
smartly written its pacing is on fast
forward and a lot of it comes across as
childish or dumb but i feel like that's
exactly what it was going for
edgy 90s venom comics weren't exactly
pushing any boundaries or telling any
stories that really redefined the medium
they just wanted to have fun with the
toothy grin of its psychotic main
character and frolic in the land of
comic book weirdness that was
inadvertently created in the 80s and in
that regard mcu i guess venom is a love
letter to those books and that
incredibly specific vibe of frantic
comic chaos
[Music]
i love this show what do you think the
review will come out eddie
[Music]
[Music]
you